dans les hôpitaux américains le combat
est loin d'être gagné
avec plus de 2000 morts en une journée
le pays est devenu le plus durement
touché par la pandémie de kobe 19 dans
le monde
l'état de new york à lui seul a
enregistré près de 800 décès dans les
dernières 24 heures un nombre horrifiant
mais qui se stabilise le confinement est
en vigueur jusqu'à la fin du mois
ensuite qu'adviendra-t-il des écoles le
gouverneur assure qu'aucune décision n'a
été prise
le maire de new york lui a statué
si les écoles demeurent fermés certaines
églises sont ouvertes
celle ci dans l'état du kentucky prévoit
tenir une messe de pâques comme prévu
l'archevêque de la nouvelle-orléans
guéri de la coved 19 a plutôt choisi de
donner la bénédiction du haut des airs à
bord d'un avion de la seconde guerre
mondiale sept autres églises de la
louisiane offre le servait son volant un
autre moyen de maintenir les traditions
tout en sauvant des vies parce que le
combat continue
ce patient est tout juste sorti des
soins intensifs
une victoire qui mérite d'être célébré
ici sébastien desrosiers radio canada
morrell